foreign
[Music]
if you ever wonder what it looks like to
lose control of your professional life
I am wearing a
[Music]
Dracula cape
I feel like Justin Bieber with this
collar popped this high
and everyone in the booth is
this looks like some of y'all look scary
man like I look over and it just looks
terrifying
there's a Halloween episode Halloween
episode is this coming out on Halloween
yes this comes out on Monday October
31st if you had just gone oh God that
would have been incredible
um so it is Halloween today so happy
Halloween everybody
um so we want to take a minute and talk
about the psychology of
horror movies
scary movies being scared
um because there's some actual real data
around it some actual real psychology
around it and uh just so happened we've
been planning this for several weeks and
it just so happened that one of my
favorite writers and podcasters names Dr
Peter attia attia he has the drive
podcast phenomenal
um it's a very very very deep dive into
how physiology Works in longevity but
it's good especially if you're a nerd
um but he wrote an article this weekend
him and uh Catherine birkenbach wrote an
article called the Paradox of horror and
so
um
I'm gonna I'm gonna go through some of
the stuff that they pull up here and
then talk about a few other ideas about
what's in the literature and the
scientific literium why we love scaring
ourselves real quick uh Ben Jen
everybody what's your favorite scary
movie of all time I have to say probably
Halloween the original but I'm a huge
fan of the new movie Black phone I've
got to see that I got it three times and
it's just amazing all right I'll see it
all right I'll check it out you've been
telling me to watch that okay Ben what
do you think I gotta say Paranormal
Activity dude like the OG the first one
that's on the very top of my list yeah
Jenna um can I just say Nightmare Before
Christmas because I don't like to be
scared well it's a cartoon but if that
scares you then no it doesn't scare me
that's why I like it or you know Edward
Scissorhands that one's pretty good too
again more of a love story
I don't like the jump scares if it's
gonna make me pee my pants I don't want
to watch it that's fair so that's fair
you
staring at me through the the glass with
that terrifying mask on he's just a
barnyard animal he's just a like a what
is that a llama
uh yeah I scare myself looking at the
camera I also don't do scary movies
uh very good okay so I think mine mine
is
my wife tells me that like back in the
day when I used to be a Rebel Rouser my
jaw would get a particular way before I
got in a fight and then I would start
laughing I would start cracking up and
the first time I saw paranormal
Paranormal Activity the original one
I went home and I was laying in my bed
laughing like I thought it was on I
could not shake that movie that was
terrifying Blair Witch Project when it
first came out there was all that hype
around it that was intense it just kept
ratcheting up and then I have to admit
the first Scream Scream one
um if you don't know Scream 1 Drew
Barrymore was at the front of was the
cast ended by spoiler alert
um just hit the fast forward button if
you don't hear it but Drew Barrymore was
the the big star at the time huge like
famous star a bunch of big movies out
and she was the first person in the
poster right and
then she's killed off in the first five
or six minutes of the movie and I
remember just being in the theater
looking at my buddy being like
what do you do what happens now I don't
know what happens now and then the whole
movie was just an unwinding of they kept
thinking like they kept leaning towards
this is who the person is this is who
the person is and it never was dude it
was awesome and then and ending I didn't
see coming it was phenomenal movie I
just remember leaving it going whoa it
was terrifying sounds of the Lambs all
those moves are terrifying all right so
here's the question that's posed um by
Dr Atia and Dr birkenbach are there any
other species on Earth that deliberately
scare ourselves do squirrels cross the
road and sit in the middle to see how
long they can wait I always wonder that
or the deer run up to wolves and like
scare them and then try to Sprint away
to see if they can make it probably not
so why do we do this is it just for
adrenaline do we do this just to amp
ourselves up Well turns out that
possibly
um it could be to improve our mental
health that sounds weird here's what the
researchers say
um this is from a study a meta-analysis
um
uh Colton Scribner and Kara Christensen
note that individuals with high anxiety
report greater enjoyment of horror than
their less anxious peers suggesting that
engagement with horror media results in
outcomes namely reduction in anxiety
symptoms that tend to reinforce this
engagement in anxious individuals sounds
weird if I go scare myself it could make
me a little less anxious so we know that
the only way through anxiety to heal it
is to go right through the middle of it
the more you run from it the more it
reinforces itself so there's something
about turning and staring it down and
here's what the authors suggest
it fully captures our attention watching
a scary movie
you getting grossed in somebody else's
life and again one of the Devils of
anxiety is it makes it about you you're
about to die you're about to get
rejected you're about to get laughed at
and when you watch a scary movie you're
you're saying to yourself they're about
to get Hatchet murdered or they're about
to get disemboweled on some cruise ship
or whatever movie you're watching I
don't know or if you're Jenna
um like Rapunzel's about to let her hair
down out of the tower I don't know what
horror movie you want but like you're
you're thinking about somebody else
right it fully engrosses you and takes
you out of yourself into somebody else's
story pretty cool
um humans are hardwired to bias their
attention towards imminent threats it's
super helpful if you're anxious when you
see somebody else's threats right
another one it gives us a sense of
control over our anxiety we have very
limited ability to change or remove most
of our day-to-day sources of anxiety
inflation job security the next possible
coveted variant all that
but murders murderous clowns on the TV
all I got to do is turn the lights on
all I got to do Kelly loves clowns
um all I gotta do is turn the film off
I'm in control of this
and the worst thing that happens here is
that person gets murdered not me right
so there's this pseudo control it
provides and this is the one that's that
resonated with me it provides a safe
means of facing threats and practicing
resilience okay practice I say that all
the time it teaches me how to practice
it teaches me how to oh gosh who's gonna
die who's gonna die and then that
tension is released the endorphins are
released and I'm still alive so in a
weird way my body is practicing being
terrified being under threat and
surviving that threat and then it
creates a physiology and a psychology
for living after the threat they go they
write some researchers have noted this
phenomenon May reflect the human desire
to learn about relevant threats and to
understand how dangerous the situation
might look
which and which reactions yield the best
income I mean outcomes it's like our
brains are practicing what happens if
there's an actual outbreak or our brains
are practicing what do we do if somebody
walks in our house in slow motion with a
hatchet and they start chopping
everybody up
um or if you're Jenna and it's a really
scary cartoon Tom and Jerry just get
right whatever's going on so
um unlike the real world counterparts
horror films have a definite endpoint we
can typically expect that they'll
conclude with a satisfying resolution of
the problem the threat is neutralized
and the good guys prevailed so it's a
way for us to enter into terrifying
situations
and be a part of them but not all the
way not all the way um it can also
promote social bonding here's a couple
of other ideas
um Dolph zilman
uh created a theory
um called excitation transfer Theory
um this suggests that
people love watching scary things
because their body rolls into fight or
flight and then it's excised
and then your body fills up with
endorphins you get high right so it's
like Runners High a little bit
um you get it's a it's feelings of
release relief or feelings of of
laughter feelings of oh like like it's
relief and so people watch scary movies
they endure the gross stuff
to get high on the back end
um the other one is a like I said it's a
way to experience fear Terror
um scary things and see them resolved
right see them end and then the final
one is curiosity
curiosity I hadn't thought of that
before but some people hear about
um
weird this and that they Wonder like I
don't know I've never seen somebody get
murdered this is a way to get the
pictures in your mind without actually
having to experience it because if you
experience it you may not make it out
and so those are some of the ideas
here's what I've found in my life
um I was obsessed big shocker with scary
movies it used to be when I was
um High School in college I saw every
single one all of them 100 of them I
never missed never never missed
um I had a buddy man we went to all of
them we got every one of those weird B
movies we could find we were all into
the
um the genre
and it did over time ratchet up my
anxiety I believe that's just me it's n
equals one experiment the more I filled
my head with that stuff the more I began
seeing threats everywhere or more
importantly experiencing feeling
threatening things somebody would walk
into a restaurant and I had a picture in
my head of the guy that walked in the
restaurant and just
you know pulls out a blowtorch and melts
everybody like I had that picture in my
head and it was an unreasonable picture
because we're at Burger King at 11 A.M
on a Wednesday right it's not gonna
happen but I had that picture in my head
it's kind of like our over consumption
of media right now we think there are
Shooters everywhere and there's not
there's not but because our media like
our news feeds cannot put out a news
feed without somebody without some
murder happening if you look at it
sometimes it'll say so and so shot and
killed by so and so
and it says Milwaukee Wisconsin and I
live in Florida right they're going to
find somewhere in the country to put
some fear in front of you because that
fear it's engrossing right
um and so I found that as I walked away
from it
I just had more peace in my life that's
just my experience and here's the other
thing when I started working with the
police department
um my dad worked in homicide and I
remember as a little kid he had a
throwaway comment he said I can't leave
you to watch this stuff for
entertainment
and I remember being like Oh you're such
an old man dude what a boring old man
when I started going into people's homes
at 2 A.M and there was actual blood and
actual guts and actual screaming and
actual weeping
dude horror movies became not fun at all
like I haven't watched one in years
because I started seeing this stuff for
real and I started sitting with people
for real and so in my life I don't need
it
um I
I missed the old scary movies I am going
to watch black phone just because uh
Kelly said it's such a great movie
um
but once I started getting involved in
the messy lives of my neighbors and
community members and family members and
Friends
man I didn't need any more I didn't need
any more scary at any more horror
anymore whatever no judgment on anybody
who does man because I dude I've been
there I love them love them love them
um but once I started actively putting
both feet into my community I got plenty
of
plenty of uh scary moments and hard
moments intense moments right
um in the world's intense and scary
place right now so let's follow Jenna's
yeah let's just uh watch some happy
stuff